der sommer
2021 ein sommer der wetter extreme
dürren und hitzerekorde
waldbrände starkregen und
überschwemmungen
wir wollen die einzelnen parteien
gegensteuern mit strengeren tempolimits
mehr bio produkten weniger inlandsflügen
und mehr solaranlagen oder soll alles
bleiben wie es ist in diesem video
schauen wir uns an welche maßnahmen in
den wahlprogrammen der parteien
vorgeschlagen werden zu
klimaneutralität
energie verkehr und mobilität
landwirtschaft und umweltschutz
klimaneutralität
klimaneutralität bedeutet nicht mehr
treibhausgase auszustoßen als gebunden
also kompensiert werden können etwa über
bäume oder moore ein entscheidender
aspekt die klimapolitik der neuen
bundesregierung
in keinem der wahlprogramme wird die
globale erwärmung bestritten und alle
heben das thema auf die große bühne
klimaschutz zur bewahrung der schöpfung
eine menschheitsaufgabe
die existenzfrage unserer zeit die große
überlebensfrage wettlauf gegen die
erwärmung die jungs der erwärmung liegt
im bereich natürlicher klimaschwankungen
die afg shirt als einzige partei in der
bewertung aus und fordert statt einen
aussichtslosen kampf gegen den wandel
des klimas zu führen sollten wir uns an
die veränderten bedingungen anpassen
sowie es pflanzen und tiere auch tun so
spricht sich die afg auch als einzige
partei strikt gegen das pariser
klimaabkommen und den sogenannten green
deal der eu aus teil dieser zwei
massnahmenpakete die begrenzung der
durchschnittlichen erderwärmung auf
deutlich unter zwei grad gegenüber der
vorindustriellen zeit dazu
klimaneutralität in der eu bis 2050
neben dutzenden weiteren maßnahmen die
fdp lehnt dieses ziel ab die fdp möchte
deutschland bis 2050 klimaneutral machen
cdu csu und spd bis 2045 so steht es
auch im aktuellen klimaschutzgesetz die
grünen fallen spätestens 2041 an die
linke
energie fünf programme verpflichten sich
der klimaneutralität geben aber
teilweise unterschiedliche wege vor muss
die politik streng regulieren oder
reichen marktwirtschaftliche anreize und
mechanismen in form von co2
emissionshandel bzw co2 bepreisung
beides bedeutet für jede tonne
kohlendioxid die ein unternehmen
ausstößt brauchen die verursacher eine
berechtigung in form von zertifikaten
die der staat ihnen verkauft
überschüssige zertifikate können
gehandelt werden in vielen bereichen
werden die kosten an die endverbraucher
weiter gereicht
die fdp setzt ausschließlich auf dieses
instrument mit blick auf
klimaneutralität chris
2050 dieses ziel können wir durch ein
striktes und jährlich sinken des co2
limit in einem umfassenden
emissionshandelssystem zuverlässig
erreichen
cdu/csu setzen hauptsächlich darauf spd
und grüne reden von diesem instrument
als einem von vielen die linke hält es
nicht für wirksam die sogenannte
eeg-umlage die seit rund 20 jahren
stromerzeugung aus erneuerbaren
energiequellen wie wind und sonne
subventioniert wollen alle sechs
parteien abschaffen oder zumindest im
fall der grünen senken und
zurückerstatten auch was die
energiequellen selbst betrifft gibt es
differenzen
die afg lehnt den bereits beschlossenen
kohleausstieg bis 2038 ab die fdp weist
darauf hin dass der ausstieg mit enormen
herausforderungen verbunden sei spd und
cdu csu bekennen sich zu dem
vereinbarten ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung
die grünen und die linke wollen diesen
schon bis 2030 vollendet sehen und bei
den erneuerbaren energien beispiel sonne
solaranlagen auf allen geeigneten
dächern vor allem auf neubauten fordern
die grünen spd und die linke die cdu
möchte die technologie ebenfalls fördern
die fdp verweist auf die bedeutung
solcher anlagen allein die afg warnt von
nachteilen der solaranlagen und sie
möchte auch mögliche standorte für
windkraftanlagen stark begrenzen alle
anderen parteien wollen in windenergie
investieren die grünen und die linke
nennen konkrete jährliche ausbauziele
verkehr und mobilität
grüne und linke wollen ab 2030 keine
neuwagen mit verbrennungsmotor mehr
zulassen spd und cdu/csu erwähnen kein
konkretes datum für das ende neuer
verbrenner fdp und fdp lehnen so einen
zulassungsstopp ab die afg spricht sich
in ihrem wahlprogramm grundsätzlich
gegen eine bevorzugung von
elektromobilität aus alle anderen
parteien beteuern den netzausbau von
ladesäulen für e autos voranbringen zu
wollen grüne und spd erwähnt
subventionen für klimafreundliche
fahrzeuge
die linke und die fdp sind explizit
dagegen
afd und fdp sind gegen eine pauschale
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung auf
autobahnen wie auch cdu/csu in deren
wahlprogramm steht
ein diesel fahrverbot lehnen wir ebenso
ab wie ein generelles tempolimit auf
autobahnen
stattdessen setzen wir auf innovative
moderne verkehrssteuerung spd und grüne
fordern eine begrenzung auf 130 km/h die
linke auf 120 nur in zwei wahlprogrammen
werden kurzstreckenflüge erwähnt die
linke möchte sie auf die schiene
verlagern wir wollen ein verbot von
flügen zu zielorten die mit dem zug in
bis zu fünf stunden erreichbar sind und
die nicht weiter als 500 kilometer
entfernt sind die grünen wollen
kurzstreckenflüge bis 2030 überflüssig
machen ebenfalls durch den ausbau des
bahnverkehrs beide parteien fordern eine
eu-weite kerosinsteuer
landwirtschaft und umweltschutz der
großteil der moore in deutschland ist
trockengelegt etwa für die
landwirtschaft dadurch zersetzt sich
nach und nach dem torf und große mengen
an treibhausgasen werden freigesetzt mit
ausnahme der afg sprechen sich alle
parteien für die wiedervernässung also
die renaturierung von mooren aus dabei
wird vorsichtig wasser zugeführt um
einen intakten wasserhaushalt
wiederherzustellen
cdu csu und spd wollen die ökologische
landwirtschaft fördern nennen aber keine
konkreten ziel marken die linke möchte
diesen sektor bis 2030 von circa zehn
prozent der flächen auf 25 prozent
ausbauen die grünen wie sie ihren 30
prozent an und möchten
den ökolandbau umfangreich fördern und
die voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass
künftig immer mehr bäuerin und
lebensmittel hersteller in umstieg afg
und fdp messen dem unterschied zwischen
herkömmlicher und biologischer
landwirtschaft weniger relevanz bei
betonen er regional und nachhaltig alle
sechs programme verweisen auf eine
kreislaufwirtschaft in der verschiedene
stoffe recycelt werden sollen und alle
beklagen dabei die zunehmende
verschmutzung der meere die spd zum
beispiel möchte unnötiges plastik
vermeiden und abschaffen dort wo ein weg
kunststoff nicht vermeidbar ist werden
wir umweltfreundliche und recyclebare
lösungen einfordern die fdp und afg
sprechen sich grundsätzlich gegen
verbote aus die grünen und die linke
bringen eine ressourcen abgabe ins spiel
etwa für einweg produkte
tendenzen auswächst wahlprogrammen mit
teils sehr unterschiedlichen ansätzen
was bis 2025 zum klimaschutz unternommen
werden sollte mit großen überschriften
das programm für stabilität und
erneuerung aus respekt vor deiner
zukunft
deutschland aber normal nie gab es mehr
zu tun zeit zu handeln
deutschland alles ist drin